July is quickly shaping up to be the hottest
month of the year, and we're not talking about
the weather.
Netflix's upcoming release schedule is a firestorm
of hot new movies and shows.
From bingeable new seasons of fan-favorite
shows to great new Netflix original horror
thrillers, there's definitely a lot to get
excited about in the upcoming weeks.
Here are all the new movies and shows coming
to Netflix in July 2018.
The Legacy of a Whitetail Deer Hunter
From Danny McBride and Jody Hill, the duo
behind HBO's Vice Principals, The Legacy of
a Whitetail Deer Hunter follows aging hunting
legend and TV personality Buck Ferguson as
he heads up into the mountains to reconnect
with his son… with Buck's cameraman, Don,
tagging along.
"Well, it HAS been two years, I dunno..."
"What you a human calendar?
Mr. Trapper Keeper.
I know how long it's been."
Sacred Games: Season 1
As India's first Netflix original series,
Sacred Games continues the service's M.O.
of bringing international talent onto their
diverse lineup.
The show is described as a dark crime thriller
and is based on the bestselling novel of the
same name.
Samantha: Season 1
Netflix made a great decision when they brought
on Brazilian series 3%, and it looks like
they're intent on tapping the country for
even more of its programming.
Samantha is an upcoming Brazilian show about
a former '80s child star who's desperate to
reach the level of fame she once had, leading
her on some wild adventures as she does everything
in her power to get back into the spotlight.
Somebody Feed Phil: The Second Course
Most people probably know Phil Rosenthal as
the creator of the long-running sitcom hit
Everybody Loves Raymond, but in recent years,
he's been on a different sort of adventure.
In Somebody Feed Phil, Rosenthal jets off
to exotic locations to check out the local
culture and cuisine.
Basically, it's like every other travel food
show, with the distinction that Rosenthal
isn't an expert on either culture or cuisine.
He's just a guy who just likes food.
"Nothing wrong with that.
And you know we like anything on a stick."
Comedians in Cars Getting Coffee: Freshly
Brewed
Jerry Seinfeld's undemanding talk show Comedians
in Cars Getting Coffee is rolling back into
Netflix with a freshly brewed batch of today's
hottest comedians.
The series' fifth collection, "Freshly Brewed,"
will see Seinfeld chatting with Dave Chappelle,
Kate McKinnon, and Zach Galifianakis, to name
a few.
First Team: Juventus: Season 1: Part B
Sports fans had a ball with the first part
of Netflix's 2018 docu-series First Team:
Juventus, which follows the Juventus football
club during their 2017 to 2018 season.
Each 40-minute episode goes behind the scenes
to take an intimate look of the players and
coaches of the Italian soccer team.
Inside the World’s Toughest Prisons: Season
They may not be too deadly to safely get a
camera crew inside, but the prisons that journalist
Paul Connolly visits in Inside the World's
Toughest Prisons definitely reek of danger.
In the first season, Connolly posed as a prisoner
in four separate lockups around the world,
living face to face with dangerous inmates.
Season 2 will see the same approach with a
new presenter - Raphael Rowe, a journalist
who himself actually spent 12 years in prison.
The Skin of The Wolf
This Spanish movie made its U.S. premiere
in March 2018 at the Miami Film Festival.
The story follows a lonely hunter who's the
last remaining resident of an abandoned town
at the top of a mountain.
Don't let the Spanish subtitles hold you back,
because there aren't many lines to read - The
Skin of the Wolf features precious little
dialogue, with long stretches containing none
at all.
Yet there's a raw, hypnotic quality to the
film that keeps it from getting boring.
White Fang
Netflix's newest animated film is bringing
Jack London's timeless tale to a whole new
audience.
Like the book, the narrative of the film is
told from the perspective of White Fang, a
half-wolf sled dog who's adopted by a Native
American tribe and learns to become a vicious
fighter.
Nick Offerman, Paul Giamatti, and Rashida
Jones lend their voices to the cast.
Make sure you check out The Legacy of a Whitetail
Deer Hunter, Sacred Games Season 1, Samantha
Season 1, Somebody Feed Phil: The Second Course,
Comedians in Cars Getting Coffee: Freshly
Brewed, First Team: Juventus, Inside the World's
Toughest Prisons: Season 2, The Skin of the
Wolf, and White Fang when they drop onto Netflix
on July 6.
Drug Lords: Season 2
A look at the most notorious criminal kingpins
in history, Drug Lords hones in on famous
names like Pablo Escobar, Frank Lucas, and
Kath Pettingill, dubbed "Granny Evil" for
her iron grip on the Melbourne drug trade.
Season 2 will raise the stakes with even more
of the head honchos of crime, from El Chapo
to Jamaican gangster Christopher Coke.
Look for it on July 10th.
How it Ends
Starring Theo James and Forest Whitaker, How
it Ends is an action thriller that follows
a man who sets off on a journey across the
country to find his pregnant girlfriend after
a mysterious apocalyptic event.
Check it out on July 13th.
Sugar Rush
Netflix has been piling on the cooking shows
lately, with Nailed It and Ugly Delicious
premiering in early 2018.
Now Sugar Rush is joining the roster.
In this cooking competition, chef Adriano
Zumbo and bakery owner Candace Nelson judge
participants who are racing against the clock
to whip up the best desserts.
It should be a sweet time, and you can catch
it all on July 13th.
Bonus Family: Season 2
In this Swedish series, family takes center
stage as two divorcees with kids move in with
each other… and bring all their emotional
baggage with them.
With everybody living under the same roof,
there's bound to be plenty of drama and comedy
alike.
Take a look at Season 2 when it drops on July
15th.
The Joel McHale Show with Joel McHale: Part
While Joel McHale's green-screened celebrity
rants originally aired as weekly episodes,
Netflix is changing up the format for the
next batch, dropping them all on the same
day.
The series sees Community star Joel McHale
poking fun at popular shows, reality TV, and
celebrities, interspersed with scripted comedy
bits.
Look for Part 2 to land on July 15th.
Amazing Interiors
With The World's Most Extraordinary Homes,
Netflix took viewers on a whirlwind tour around
the globe to visit a few of the craziest looking
homes in existence.
With Amazing Interiors, the format continues
- only this time, the crazy is all inside.
What will you find when you walk through the
doors of these homes?
Find out on July 20th.
Dark Tourist
Instead of visiting the usual cultural highlights
around the world, Dark Tourist pinpoints the
planet's most morbid settings, such as abandoned
nuclear reactors and haunted forests.
Journalist and filmmaker David Farrier leads
the charge, promising a weird journey into
the unexpected.
Take the plunge on July 20th.
Father of the Year
David Spade headlines this coming-of-age comedy,
which sees two boys coming home from college.
When they get into an argument about who's
father could beat up the other's father, one
of their dads steps up to the challenge.
Hijinks ensue.
Take a look on July 20th.
Last Chance U
For two seasons, Netflix tagged along as the
troubled teens of East Mississippi Community
College, or EMCC, fought to return to Division
1 status and achieve their football dreams.
Nicknamed Last Chance U, EMCC offered many
of these players their last shot at redemption.
For the third season, Netflix is releasing
a two-parter.
The first takes a look at the players who
left EMCC after the first two seasons and
is called, appropriately, Last Chance U: EMCC
& Life After.
The second - Last Chance U: INDY: Part 1 - starts
up the new season at a new school: Independence
Community College in Kansas.
The expectations are lower, but the stakes
are higher than ever.
Look for both to land on July 20th.
The Warning
Keep your eyes peeled for Spanish thriller
The Warning.
When a ten-year-old boy finds a note in a
gas station that seems to predict his death,
he'll have to team up with a mysterious stranger
to figure out what's going on before it's
too late.
Get ready for all the twists and turns when
The Warning shows up on July 24th.
Extinction
This sci-fi thriller stars Michael Pena as
a father who's recurring nightmares about
an alien invasion come true.
When actual aliens attack the planet, he'll
have to fight to keep his family safe from
the extraterrestrial threat.
Lizzy Caplan and Luke Cage's Mike Colter co-star.
Look for Extinction on July 27th.
Roman Empire: Reign of Blood: Master of Rome
Netflix's docu-drama series Roman Empire:
Reign of Blood has spent two years thrilling
fans with its historical look at the beginnings
of the fall of Rome.
The series uses actors and sets to play out
the drama, while the occasional voiceover
or talking head pops in to provide documentary-style
commentary on what's going on.
The upcoming Roman Empire: Reign of Blood:
Master of Rome will follow the same format,
and this time, the focus is on Julius Caesar.
Queue it up on July 27th.
Orange is the New Black: Season 6
For five seasons, Piper and her friends have
regaled audiences in one of the most engaging
and original shows in recent memory.
We've seen relationships form, flourish and
wither, all within the halls of Litchfield
prison.
Judging by the brief teaser for the new season,
the show will pick up right where fans last
saw Piper and the remaining inmates in the
Season 5 cliffhanger.
Look for it on July 27th.
The Bleeding Edge
Through candid interviews with patients and
medical professionals, The Bleeding Edge paints
a terrifying picture of medical devices rushed
through safety testing and installed in hospitals
across the country.
There's nothing more terrifying than a medical
horror story, so it's sure to be an eye-opening
experience.
Take a look on July 27th.
A Very Secret Service: Season 2
This goofy spy comedy is sort of like the
French answer to Get Smart.
With both hard-hitting drama and absurd comedy,
the first season of A Very Secret Service
built a loyal - if small - fan base.
The second season promises more of the same.
Don't miss it when it arrives on Netflix on
July 30th.
Terrace House: Opening New Doors: Part 3
Inexplicably one of Netflix's more popular
shows, Terrace House operates on the basic
premise that a reality show doesn't need any
scripting whatsoever to draw in viewers.
This Japanese series is low key, drama free,
and utterly hypnotizing for no discernible
reason.
Part 3 of the spinoff Opening New Doors hits
on July 31st.
Original stand-up comedy
Netflix is offering a different take on comedy
this July.
In addition to two full-length specials, Netflix
is also releasing a stand-up collection titled
The Comedy Lineup, which will see multiple
comedians take the stage for short sets.
That shows up on July 3rd, and you also can
catch Jim Jefferies: This Is Me Now on July
13th, followed by Iliza Shlesinger : Elder
Millennial on July 24th.
That wraps up all the Netflix originals arriving
in July 2018, so let's turn to everything
else being added to the streaming service
next month.
New movies
As far as Netflix is concerned, blockbuster
season officially begins on July 1st.
The first of the month will dawn with classic
action films like the Jurassic Park trilogy,
The Boondock Saints, and Van Helsing.
July 1st will also see the arrival of some
great dramas, such as Menace II Society, and
We Own the Night.
Later in the month, you can look for Blue
Valentine on the 5th, Gone Baby Gone on the
12th, and Her on the 29th.
For laughs, don't miss Ryan Reynolds' 2014
dark comedy The Voices, which sees Reynolds
as a slightly psychopathic blue collar worker.
"You know I'm a talking cat.
There's no such thing.
Everything I say, is really you."
"That's true buddy.
It's all you."
"Whaaaaaaaat?"
That's arriving on the first, alongside the
return of Bo Burnham's stand-up special what.
Finally, Kevin Hart: Let Me Explain is dropping
on the 13th.
Netflix is also rolling out plenty of options
for the family to watch together.
Look for Finding Neverland, the two Scooby-Doo
movies, and The Princess Diaries on July 1st,
followed by Disney's Bolt on the 22nd.
Unfortunately, July is going to be slim pickings
for the horror fans in the room.
There are only two upcoming films on the docket:
Deceived arrives on July 1st, and Scream 4
arrives on July 7th.
New television
If Netflix is coming up short in some of their
movie categories, they're more than making
up for it with their television selection.
You can escape the summer heat with new seasons
of Blue Bloods, Hawaii Five-O, NCIS, and Madam
Secretary on the first.
July 2nd sees the arrival of Season 4 of The
Good Witch and Season 1 of The Sinner, and
July 6 will herald the addition of The Fosters:
Season 5.
Finally, July 28th will bring the dysfunctional
Gallagher family back home as Season 8 of
Shameless arrives.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!